[Musik]
also was habt ihr vor das ist eigentlich
ganz einfach wir wollen unsere store
bereit lieferservice anschließen
das willst du doch schon lange aber
jetzt habe ich jemanden gefunden nämlich
unterstützt
ernsthaft das könnte sehr profitabel
werden nicht verstehe was habe ich damit
zu tun
ich möchte dass der lieferservice
umweltfreundlich ist deshalb weil wir
mit dem fahrrad anfangen das ist
umweltfreundlich und spart auch
benzinkosten das geht zwar nicht wenn es
schneit aber sonst eigentlich immer
und ihr wollt fahrräder von mir ja aber
nicht nur fahrräder das geschäft soll
sich auch sonst für dich lohn wie denn
naja du steigst in das projekt als
geschäftspartnerin mit ein und wird dann
am gewinn beteiligt das risiko wird er
natürlich auch geteilt wenn dir der
vorschlag zu riskant ist dann mieten wir
die fahrräder einfach nur bei dir und
auf unserem flyer und in der app wird
dann werbung für deinen laden gemacht
die idee ist gut aber ich kann jetzt
keinen kredit aufnehmen
das ist vielleicht gar nicht nötig wieso
ich keine eigene investor der interesse
hat ein investor wie groß soll das
geschäft mit dem lieferservice dann
werden naja so groß ist